double Trump is keeping India in
suspense after it's signed a massive
weapons deal with Russian the u.s.
leader is deciding whether to punish New
Delhi for buying Russian s14 air defense
systems or give a presidential waiver
either way he's keeping his cards close
to his chest India's gonna find out
all right they you'll see sooner than
you think Russia is currently India's
biggest arms supplier and that meeting
earlier this month between the two
countries leaders saw them boost that
even further striking there you go a
five billion dollar deal to supply India
with the s400 anti-missile defense
system it is one of the world's most
sophisticated surface-to-air weapons
they system has a range of 400
kilometres it can shoot down up to 80
targets simultaneously
and besides India Russian s400 s have
been purchased by countries including
China
Algeria Belarus and Turkey International
Affairs professor Sturm Giulia believes
Trump's threat is less about politics
than business leverage I think this is
more like posturing and it's Trump's
bargaining style to introduce
uncertainty and unpredictability and to
then you know drive you know a deal and
that he thinks to keep the other party
in tenterhooks and then to say okay I'm
willing to reconsider this but what will
you give me in return so this is part of
his transactional diplomacy and I think
he's looking at India buying more US
defence equipment for example he may
also be looking at you know the India
opening market access to civilian
American exports because there's also as
you know parallely a trade war that's
been going on so the options I mean he
will forfeit a lot of influence and
leverage in this country if he does the
unthinkable and actually slap sanctions
on us
you